hat er vor dem mülheimer gekackt oder
mein name ist luca und meine damen und
herren ich habe so unfassbar viele
kommentare bekommen von wegen ich
sondern die das im stil hochladen
da das bin ich in meine erstellung
meinem zimmer habe ich mir halt diesen
kommentar zu herzen genommen dass ich
halt ein model erstellen soll
aber ja freunde ihr seht schon wir
befinden uns hier in einer komplett
neuen map der alte spielstand den ich
noch in den sims folgen hatte die ich
vor einigen monaten mit 24 jahren
hochgeladen haben habe ich gelöscht weil
ich wollte dass das sie jetzt eine
richtige serie 40 dementsprechend
wöchentlichen 95 hochladen und nicht
auch offiziere also ihr könnt in die
kommentare schreiben was sich jeweils
machen soll in der folge dann gilt
allerdings will ich sagen klicke ich
jetzt erstmal auf play denn wir sind ja
gerade erst hier eingezogen
hier ist ein typ trent hecking ich würde
sagen ich klicke einfach mal auf ihn
drauf
wir können den nachbarn herein bitten in
welches haus dan diker wir vorne steht
auch noch ein auf unserem grundstück
der hat ja das ist auch brand hecking
und der typische vorne heißt auch brand
hecking moment sehr hier wird mit e
geschrieben und der hiermit aber haben
zwei nachbarn die genau gleich heißen
außer der teile mit der anderen wird
angeschrieben wird ich will allerdings
sagen wir unterhalten uns erstmal mit
dem hier vorne also du bist dieser brand
heck hin du bist ja ein nachbar von mir
ich bin gerade erst hergezogen
ich bin nämlich großer dj du machst
diese musik der ist mir jetzt schon
unsympathisch das heißt ich würde sagen
wir gehen mal rüber zu unserem anderen
nachbarn hier
er hat auch das hier mit gummi
obstkuchen
die kuchen essen alle meine freunde sind
verschwunden luca steht hier auf jeden
fall ganz alleine und ich würde sagen
wir bauen uns jetzt erstmal ein haus
verschicken den spätesten rund hallo
bistum hund er das ist eine katze mit
einem hut auf luca geht jetzt der katze
hin gibt ihm die hand und unterhält
da ist ein 2 was ist das sieht nicht so
gesund aus wir brauchen aber auf jeden
fall erstmal ein haus ich brauche jetzt
erst mal das wichtigste und zwar machen
wir jene lange wand hing aus scheiße ich
möchte auf jeden fall dass es diesmal
keine cheats tipps projekt wird deswegen
werde ich jetzt erstmal nur so die sage
ich mal günstigsten sachen an das bett
stellen einfach mal mitten im raum hier
vorne und dann braucht man auch ein
kühlschrank den packe ich einfach mal
hierhin erhält kommt direkt daneben
nicht zu vergessen die schöne mülltonne
hier vorne sich jetzt aber trotzdem noch
mal eine wand lang und zwar kommt hier
das bad hin
da muss ich dann auch noch mal die
fenster hier weg machen so ein paar
letzte toilette was schmeckt den
handtuchhalter und die dusche ein
bisschen dunkel das heißt da kommen
jetzt auch noch kurze lampe rein ich
würd sagen wir mal war die hier
wie gesagt wir haben nicht viel geld
über den kompletten boden mache ich
jetzt einfach mal irgend so ein paar
caps hier noch so ein cooles sofa hin
dann hier so ein geiler fernseher an die
wand hier noch eine coole lampe und
jedoch eine stehlampe in die ecke glaube
ich das ganze erst einmal eingerichtet
es ist solle typische studentenwohnungen
würde ich sagen die frage ist nur wo
sich luca grad befindet auch der haupt-
noch da wurde die katze gesehen hat wir
sind jetzt auf jeden fall gerade neu
eingezogen in der stadt das heißt ich
würde sagen wir lassen luca erstmal in
seinem haus reihen laufen und schauen
wir es findet ich bin gespannt wie er
das ganze haus findet er es jetzt zum
ersten mal so wirklich drin natürlich
klar sowas hätte man auch anders machen
können allerdings bin ich jetzt echt man
auf seine meinung gespannt
wie er das kajak hier ist auch noch ein
bisschen dunkel er denkt natürlich
direkt ans fernsehen da kann er sich
aber cool auf die couch setzen hier
fehlt vielleicht auch ein couchtisch
also eigentlich ist das haus komplett
das heißt ich würde sagen wir stellen
uns jetzt erstmal einige nachbarn vor
das hat ja zu beginn nicht so gut
geklappt hat du machst diese musik aber
schauen wir mal ob wir bei anderen
mitbewohnern der stadt mehr glück haben
ich bin jemand der ein handy besitzt
weil ich habe richtig viel geld und das
kommt alles daher weil ich ja so gut
malen kann ich gehe da jetzt mal ok also
der typ auf jeden fall nicht so cool
drauf fragen was sie einfach mal was mit
er hier abgeht ich kann
luftballonfiguren machen mit meinem mund
weil so sehe ich halt aus und das kann
ich machen so siehst du aus okay das ist
natürlich hast du denn im bett bei dir
zu hause audi wieder direkt auf den
punkt kommen ich habe immer im privatjet
weil ich bin unfassbar bekannter gamer
und verdient so viel geld was du hast
den drachen habe ich eine ahnung was das
für vollidioten da sind allerdings würde
ich sagen bevor wir uns jetzt noch
weitere nachbarn vorstellen schauen wir
uns doch erstmal zusammen unserer
nachbarschaft überhaupt an also das hier
ist unser kleines haus auf unserem auch
sehr sehr kleinen grundstücken hier
nebenan wohnen leute hier ist dann die
innenstadt glaube ich also hier wurden
auch noch viele leute da ist die kirche
und so weiter und so fort
hier ist ein
habe ich irgendwie ein haustier version
installiert oder was es das erst schön
irgendwelche katzen überall rum hier
vorne läuft auch schon wieder irgendwie
katze rum und es ist ja auch noch 100
park oder was auch immer das ist aber
egal hier ist einfach auch in katzen
denkmal allesklar.de wie vor dass auf
jeden fall dieser kleine park mit dem
denkmal hier vorne wurden dann auch noch
mal andere leute hier sind noch freie
grundstücke hier wohnt auch noch eine
andere familie und hier ist ein kleiner
fluss da kann man her laufen hier kann
man wahrscheinlich angeln oder keine
ahnung und dann wohnen hier wieder wie
luca wie geht es denn die eigentlich
energie geladen wir besuchen jetzt
einfach mal zusammen mit der frau die
wir gerade kennengelernt haben den park
hier vorne
luca macht direkt schon passiert ups und
die frau läuft weg vor uns war megageil
parkbesuch lukas ja auf jeden fall sehr
energiegeladen das heißt er müsste ich
auf jeden fall lohnen einen guten hund
ist er jetzt gerade in die arabische das
war mehr willst du dich nicht denen aber
gut dann kriegen wir mal hier auf
training und dann machen wir mal
liegestütze hier
luca will sportlich und dann jetzt noch
joggen gehen denn das für ein outfit und
warum ist ja so stabil alter ich bin das
nicht also luca joggt jetzt hier auf
jeden fall ein bisschen rum die frage
ist halt wo diese summer holiday ist ist
aber auch egal
wir sind zurück auf dem parkett luca was
er sieht
bisschen aus wie sollen obdachlose geht
jetzt hier mitten in der nacht auf dem
park und schmeißt da irgendwie den grill
an und ich weiß noch nicht was das von
outfit ist luca du kannst nicht immer
wieder sagt feindt
das sind einfach sechs hot dogs da kommt
die summer holiday an freunde also die
sitzen jetzt neben mich möchte auch was
essen war ich liebe ja die sonne nur
wegen der ist es ja immer so schön warm
und dann kann man mit dem auto rum
fahren und da muss man den müll nicht
mehr raus bringen weil der ist ja dann
ich gern ihre bilder und so und pakete
bemalte ich auch echt gern ja wenn ich
dann irgendwie verschicken muss es
scheiße mein zug fährt gleich oh mein
gott hilft gerade einfach irgendwie so
ein hund lang
der denkt auch an sport waren was ist
denn mit euch scheiß auf dieses mädel
ich weiß nicht was jetzt gerade seine
mission ist er mehr läuft auf die bank
zu und setzt sich
er geht den musiker ab was machst du
denn vor dem lämmer gepackt oder also
ich habe keine ahnung was ein problem
ist das wird uns ja hier angezeigt und
zwar ist er schmutzer okay das erklärt
natürlich einiges
wir kennen diese frau halt wirklich seit
ein paar minuten und jetzt könnt ihr
einfach in unserem haus während wir
duschen
du kannst es derzeit beim duschen
er ist fertig ich frag mich mittlerweile
wirklich gar nichts mehr
holiday hat uns wieder verlassen und ein
neuer tag es angebrochen
lokal ist schon sein frühstück schaut
dabei einfach auf den screen drauf
summer holiday möchte vorbeikommen und
abhängen ist das in ordnung
okay da kommt die sommer angelaufen mit
ihrem regenschirm ja knopf mal schön an
luca luka da steht vor der tür
ist es vielleicht bei dem die tür
aufmachen aber mal schauen was die sache
so zu berichten hat bordeaux sieht echt
aus jülich wird extra mal vorbeikommen
wir das zu sagen hier das bin ich und
ich ziehe mich aus wie müll nur damit du
weißt ja doch also dein gesicht erinnert
mich schon ziemlich stark an eine
schublade ja beiden sind jetzt auf jeden
fall hier zusammen haben fernseh gucken
meine lieben freunde wären eigentlich
für die erste folge sie erzählt wieder
irgendwas mit müll wir haben für die
erste folge von diesem neuen sims
projekt auf jeden fall echt einiges
geschafft ich habe hier ein kleines
häuschen auf die beine gestellt auch
wenn es echt ziemlich beschissen ist
haben uns ein bisschen eingelebt in der
stadt wir haben schon umgeschaut ein
paar leute kennengelernt unter anderem
auch sie die summer holiday beide
verstehen sich auf jeden fall echt gut
das heißt jetzt meine lieben freund ich
hab ich ja gesagt ich möchte mich ein
bisschen auf euch auf eure kommentare
eingehen schreibt mir von daher jetzt
war unten in die kommentare was sich in
der nächsten folge nächste woche dann
machen soll solche neuen teams erstellen
soll ich irgendwie einen job mich darum
bemühen 1 bekommen oder soll ich
vielleicht gucken ob ich einen hund
kriege oder so schreibt sie auf jeden
fall in die kommentare wenn ihr bock
drauf habe dass euer kommentar eventuell
in der nächsten folge die nächste woche
hier eingeblendet wird und wir das
machen was du dir dann wünscht dass ein
daumen hoch bei diesem video hier da
wenn es dir gefallen hat das wird mich
mega mega voll und abonniert main kanal
falls du noch keinen teil der luxus
seite
[Musik]